the most important days in your life
are the day you are born
and the day you find out why
my works are like water
the works of the great masters are like
wine
but everyone drinks water
of all the animals
man is the only one that is cruel
he is the only one that inflicts pain
for the pleasure of doing it
man was made at the end of the week's
work
when god was tired
be careful about reading health books
you may die of a misprint
the noblest work of god
man who found it out
man
never argue with stupid people
they will drag you down to their level
and then beat you with experience
if you tell the truth
you don't have to remember anything
the truth must be served like a coat
and not thrown in the face like a wet
towel
circumstances make man
not man's
circumstances the average human being
is a perverse creature
and when he isn't that
he is a practical joker
let us live so that when we come to die
even the undertaker will be sorry
everyone is a moon
and has a dark side which he never shows
to anybody
clothes make the man
naked people have little or no influence
in society
[Music]
there are no people who are quite so
vulgar
as the over-refined ones
if you pick up a starving dog
and make him prosperous
he will not bite you
this is the principal difference between
a dog
and man
concerning the difference between man
and the jackass
some observers hold that there isn't any
such is the human race
often it does seem such a pity
that noah didn't miss the boat
keep away from people who try to
belittle your ambitions
small people always do that
but the really great make you feel that
you
too
[Music]
can become great
man will do many things to get himself
loved
he will do all things to get himself
envied
wrinkles should merely indicate
where the smiles have been
adam and eve had many advantages
but the principal one was that they
escaped teething
some civilized women
would lose half their charm without
dress
and some would lose all of it
one frequently only finds out how really
beautiful a beautiful woman is
after considerable acquaintance with her
there is only one good sex
the female one
it takes much to convince the average
man of anything
and perhaps nothing can ever make him
realize
that he is the average woman's inferior
no civilization can be perfect
until exact equality between men and
women is included
take any type of woman
and you will find in it something to
respect
something to admire
something to love
we lavish gifts upon children
but the most precious gift our personal
association
which means so much to them
we give grudgingly
a baby is an inestimable blessing
and bother
after all these years
i see that i was mistaken about eve in
the beginning
it is better to live outside the garden
with her than inside it without her
when you fish for love
bait with your heart
not your brain
you can't reason with your heart
it has its own laws and thumps about
things which the intellect scorns
no woman or man
really knows what perfect love is
until they have been married a quarter
of a century
do right
and you will be conspicuous
a man should not be without morals
it is better to have bad morals than
none at all
be good
and you will be lonesome
better a broken promise than none at all
i am an old man
and have known a great many troubles
but most of them never happened
courage is resistance to fear
mastery of fear not absence of fear
kindness is a language which the deaf
can hear
and the blind can see
all you need in this life is ignorance
and confidence
then success is sure
the man who does not read has no
advantage over the man
who cannot read
forgiveness is the fragrance that the
violet sheds on the heel that has
crushed it
a banker is a fellow who lends you his
umbrella when the sun is shining
but wants it back the minute it begins
to rain
the fear of death follows from the fear
of life
a man who lives fully is prepared to die
at any time
to get the full value of joy
you must have someone to divide it with
anger is an acid that can do more harm
to the vessel in which it is stored
than to anything on which it is poured
virtue has never been as respectable as
money
few things are harder to put up with
than the annoyance of a good example
nothing so needs reforming
as other people's habits
a man may have no bad habits
and have worse
we can secure other people's approval
if we do it right and try hard
but our own is worth the hundred of it
and no way has been found out of
securing that
always obey your parents
when they are present
this is the best policy in the long run
because if you don't
they will make you
the human race has only one really
effective weapon
and that is laughter
when i was a boy of 14
my father was so ignorant i could hardly
stand to have the old man around
but when i got to be 21
i was astonished at how much the old man
had learned in seven years
a sin takes on new and real terrors when
there seems a chance
that it is going to be found out
the more things are forbidden
the more popular they become
in order to make a man or a boy covet a
thing
it is only necessary to make the thing
difficult to attain
only two things we'll regret
on deathbed
that we are a little loved
and little traveled
always acknowledge fault frankly
this will throw those in authority off
guard
and give you an opportunity
to make a choice
conscience takes up more room than all
the rest of a person's insides
there are several good protections
against temptations
but the surest is cowardice
courage is resistance to fear
mastery of fear
not absence of fear
eat a live frog first thing in the
morning
and nothing worse will happen to you the
rest of the day
never argue with a fool
onlookers may not be able to tell the
difference
there are not enough morally brave men
in stock
we are out of moral courage material
to believe yourself brave
is to be brave
it is better to deserve honors and not
have them than to have them and not
deserve them
when people do not respect us we are
sharply offended
yet in his private heart
no man respects himself much
human pride is not worthwhile
there is always something lying in wait
to take the wind out of it
by trying
we can easily learn to endure adversity
man will do many things to get himself
loved
he will do all things to get himself
envied
the universal brotherhood of man is our
most precious possession
what there is of it
when i was younger
i could not remember anything
whether it had happened or not
but my faculties are decaying now
and soon i shall be so i cannot remember
any
but the things that never happened
it is sad to go to pieces like this
but we all have to do it
noise proves nothing
often a hen who has laid an egg cackles
as if she had laid an asteroid
[Music]
loyalty to petrified opinions never yet
broke a chain or freed a human's soul
there is no character however good and
fine
but it can be destroyed by ridicule
however poor and witless
the secret source of humor itself
is not joy but sorrow
chastity
it can be carried too far
modesty died when clothes were born
honesty
the best of all the lost arts
each race determines for itself what
indecencies are
nature knows no indecencies
man invents them
when angry
count to four when very angry
swear
we begin to swear before we can talk
in certain trying circumstances
urgent circumstances
desperate circumstances
profanity furnishes a relief denied even
to prayer
grief can take care of itself
but to get full value of a joy
you must have somebody to divide it with
loyalty to country always
loyalty to government
when it deserves it
be careless in your dress if you must
but keep a tidy soul
prosperity is the best protector of
principle
one of the proofs of the immortality of
the soul
is that myriads have believed in it
they have also believed the world was
flat
if i cannot swear in heaven i shall not
stay there
there is no sadder sight
than a young pessimist
it is a wise child that knows its own
father
and an unusual one that unreservedly
approves of him
the man who was a pessimist before 48
knows too much
if he is an optimist after it he knows
too little
at zero dollars a man can be an ass
without being an optimist
but not an optimist without being an ass
by land
they're not making it anymore
pessimist
the optimist who didn't arrive
a person with a new idea is a crank
until the idea succeeds
whatever a man's age
he can reduce it by several years by
putting a bright colored flower in his
buttonhole
we have permanent habits until we are
forty
then they begin to harden
presently
they
petrify then business begins
we should be careful to get out of and
experience only the wisdom that is in it
and stop there
whoever has lived long enough to find
out what life is
knows how deep a debt of gratitude we
owe to adam
the first great benefactor of our race
he brought death into the world
the lack of money is the root of all
evil
when in doubt tell the truth
all say
how hard is it
that we have to die
a strange complaint coming from the
mouths of people who have had to live
truth is the most valuable thing we have
let us economize it
giving up smoking is the easiest thing
in the world
i know because i've done it thousands of
times
no real gentleman will tell the naked
truth in the presence of the ladies
honesty is the best policy
when there is money in it
some people lie when they tell the truth
i tell the truth
lying
as by the fire of experience
so by commission of crime
you learn real morals
i never could tell a lie that anyone
would doubt
nor a truth that anyone would
[Music]
believe an honest man in politics shines
more than he would elsewhere
when your friends begin to flatter you
on how young you look
it's a sure sign you're getting old
a lie can travel halfway around the
world
while the truth is putting its shoes on
one of the striking differences between
a cat and a lie
is that a cat has only nine lives
a truth is not hard to kill
a lie told well is immortal
do something every day that you don't
want to do
this is the golden rule for acquiring
the habit of doing your duty without
pain
there are 869 different forms of lying
but only one of them has been squarely
forbidden
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
i can't stand george eliot and hawthorne
and those people
i see what they are at a hundred years
before they get to it
and they just tire me to death
the only way to keep your health is to
eat what you don't want
drink what you don't like
and do what you'd rather not
i have made it a rule never to smoke
more than one cigar at a time
it is the little conveniences that make
the real comfort of life
24 years ago i was strangely handsome
the remains of it still visible through
the rifts of time
to be busy is man's only happiness
the exercise of an extraordinary gift
is the supremest pleasure in life
do not put off till tomorrow what can be
put off till day after tomorrow just as
well
[Music]
there are people who can do all fine and
heroic things but one
keep from telling their happiness to the
unhappy
against the assault of laughter
nothing can stand
there is no such thing as a new joke
when red-headed people are above a
certain social grade
their hair is auburn
it is human to exaggerate the merits of
the dead
the man with a new idea
is a crank until the idea succeeds
thunder is good
thunder is impressive
but it is the lightning that does the
work
i like a good story well told
that is the reason i am sometimes forced
to tell them myself
unexpected money is a delight
the same sum is a bitterness when you
expect more
you